Today, I want to look at how the global
economy will collapse.
Specifically, how the US economy will
collapse because of this war.
Now, the argument I want to make to you
today is that financial collapse do not
happen accidentally or naturally. It has
to be engineered.
And this is a very hard concept for us
to understand, okay? So, uh in
economics,
there's something called the
boom-bust cycle.
>> [clears throat]
>> Which basically states that in
capitalism,
you have
um
the economy booming, then suddenly, for
whatever reason, it collapses, okay?
It's called a boom-bust cycle.
And
the idea is that if you study economics,
they teach you that this is just a
natural part of capitalism because in
good times, people spend too much money.
They become overconfident.
And so, then they uh waste a lot of
money, and then it collapses. The
economy turns bad, and so, you have to
focus on being more lean and efficient
and resilient. So, think of
you know,
gaining weight, okay? You gain too much
weight, and then you feel bad, so then
you lose weight.
And that's the idea of um
the boom-bust cycle.
The problem, though, is that no one can
explain properly
how and why
suddenly
the bubble pops, okay? What's the
mechanism
or trigger
for the collapse?
If you study economics,
you will never ever know the answer. So,
we are going to focus on speculation
today, okay?
So, again,
um the internet knows this, but I've
never studied economics.
I don't know much about economics,
but I'm curious as to why this happens,
okay? Why is it that bubbles pop? How
does um econ- how do economies rise and
fall, okay? So, I'm not an ex- expert.
I'm not even a professor. Yes, I
understand. But, what I do is I engage
in speculation for fun, for
entertainment, okay? So, just see this
as a fun class where we're going to
explore some fun topics that have no
scholarly basis, okay? All right. So,
just keep this in mind, guys. All right.
So, let's look at very quickly
the main explanation for why booms and
busts happens. And this is from uh
Andrew Ross Sorkin, who is probably the
most influential financial journalist in
America.
And he wrote a book called 1929, which
looks at the stock market collapse of
1929, and he offers a very good
explanation as to why it happened, okay?
So, Emma, could you read from me,
please? Of course.
Lengthy, uninterrupted booms, like the
one in the 1920s, produce a collective
delusion. Optimism becomes a drug or a
religion or some combination of both.
People lose their ability to calculate
risk and distinguish between good ideas
and bad ones. Okay, so again, this is
the same explanation for why there's a
bubble burst, because it's delusional,
and then it's like you fly too high,
okay? But, you're not you're not
supposed to fly, so then you fall down
to the ground eventually.
It's just gravity, okay? The idea of
gravity.
But, I want to What What to show you
today is
there's actually another explanation,
which is this is all being engineered.
There are people behind the scenes with
the power to cause economies to rise and
to fall, okay? So, let me give you an
example of this.
All right.
Let's just say you're a bank.
All right? You're a bank.
And your job is to
take those money, save it, and then use
it properly in order to um promote the
economy, okay?
So, let's just say
we put a million dollars
into the bank.
Okay? And what does the bank do with it?
The The bank then lends it out to
entrepreneurs.
Right? So, maybe I want to start a
restaurant, and so I borrow a million
dollars from the bank.
Okay?
Question. How much money is in the bank
now?
It should be zero, right?
Okay, that's That's math, guys. Look, if
I take in a million dollars and I lend
it out a million dollars, I should have
zero cuz that's just basic math.
But that's not the answer. The actual
answer is two million dollars.
>> [clears throat]
>> And
what you need to understand is that each
bank has the ability to print its own
money.
And the bank is a mechanism for
liquidity in the economy, okay?
And this is a great illusion. Like, this
is a delusion, okay?
Um behind the economy, where money is
just a
It's just an idea. It's a concept. It's
a collective hallucination.
All right? Um now,
but the problem is there are thousands,
tens of thousands of banks everywhere.
So, how do they know
>> [clears throat]
>> how to coordinate together? Okay? And
this is something else you need to
understand about the system. There's
actually something called a signaling
mechanism.
Signaling
Okay?
Um so, all these banks are separate, but
they are linked together into something
called a central bank. Okay? Central
bank.
>> [snorts]
>> And what does central bank What does
central bank do? The central bank
signals
whether or not to lend money
or not to lend money. And it's in this
mechanism that's called the interest
rate.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay?
Now, again, if you study economics, what
they will teach you is that depending on
the interest rate, if it's low, maybe
1%,
or 5%, or high 5%, then that will
determine how consumers behave.
If the interest rate is 1%, what this
means is I can go to the bank, get
money, and buy a house.
Right? If it's too high, 5%, then I
don't want to go to the bank to buy a
house. And this is what you're taught in
in
economics class.
But there's actually another
explanation, which is the interest rate
is not to signal consumers or homeowners
to buy, but rather for banks to lend or
not.
Okay, doesn't make sense?
Because the banks, what they can do is
depending on the interest rate, they
know that okay, my job is to release
more liquidity into the system, release
more money into the system, and
therefore I will make it easier
to take out a loan. Okay?
But if the interest rate is high, then I
know, okay, I must not release too much
liquidity in the system, therefore I
will make the loan application hard.
Okay?
So, in other words, the interest rate is
not
it is not set in order to guide consumer
behavior, it is set in order to
coordinate liquidity in the marketplace.
Okay, doesn't make sense? Okay. So,
these are two very curious aspects
of this system that people don't really
understand.
So, in order to understand the system, I
will explain to you how the world works.
Okay, now I explained this before, but I
want to summarize and apply it to this
scenario scenario, okay? So, the first
thing to understand is that we live in
Plato's cave.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay, meaning that we're all chained to
the floor and we're all watching a
screen. And behind is this great fire
where the elite create uh puppets for so
that we can collectively hallucinate our
own reality. All right?
And this mechanism
that allows us to coordinate our
imagination is of course called money.
All right, so think of money as
God.
Right? And so, what money is doing is
it's focusing our minds in a certain way
that creates our reality.
All right?
So, remember
remember this idea and keep this in
mind. Okay, so because of this concept,
this allows us to create the world that
we live in today. Okay? So, remember how
the world is structured.
Um you have the empire.
But then you have the game masters.
Who are the game masters? They're the
people in finance.
Okay, and this includes Bank of
International Settlements,
um World Bank,
uh International Monetary Fund,
uh Wall Street, City of London. Okay,
these these are different financial
organizations that coordinate together
and they're the game masters.
And what they do is they control how US
dollars, which is the currency of this
game, they control how US dollars
um moves around the system, okay? So,
USD.
And this creates, of course, the global
economy.
>> [clears throat]
>> But you cannot
allow people to think that they're
actually a set of people manipulating
this game because then people will think
this is not fair. It's not transparent.
Right?
It's And it it's not a clean game. So,
what you do is you create multilateral
organizations
called the rules-based international
order
like the WTO, UN.
And you make them to believe that, "Oh,
it's these impartial
organizations that actually control the
game. So, it's fair and it's
transparent. It's accountable to the
people." Okay? And then you reinforce
this using media,
um education, and culture.
And together these three will
um
create the values and norms
that make us believe that this is a
fair, open, and transparent game in
which we can all win.
Okay? So, that when there's a collapse,
it's not because there are people
engineering this collapse behind the
scenes, it's because it's a law of
gravity. It's This is happens naturally
in this game. It's no one's fault. It's
just like we were too lazy and corrupt,
okay?
All right. So, certain things to
remember about the system is that this
system is not as clean as you think
because there are opposing forces to it.
All right. And these opposing forces are
such forces such as
nationalism.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay? Or ethnic identity. Then you have
social democracy.
Individual rights, right? And then and
then of course you have religion.
All right, so there are these
countervailing forces that try to break
apart the system. So then what happens
is that there are other
um systems that keep the system in place
and respond to these countervailing
forces, all right? And they are
intelligence,
spies, basically, crime,
and science.
And behind these three forces
are three sets of powerful institutions,
okay? These are
transnational capital,
um secret societies,
and the last is elite families.
Okay? Some people call Some people call
them the uh Illuminati, okay? It doesn't
matter. All right?
So this is how the world works. And
underpinning
uh this elite is something called the
occult, which we'll study later on,
okay?
All right. So certain things that stand
out about the system that you may notice
is, "Hey guys, look.
Transnational capital
is also
the game masters as well as the global
economy, okay?
This is important because remember, this
system is the parasite.
And this system is the host.
So transnational capital is both the
parasite as well as the host. It's both
the game master as well as the player.
Okay? So this obviously leads to a lot
of corruption.
So then the question then then is, how
do we get this system? Where did this
system come from?
So, so let me go into some history,
okay?
So, the year is 1688.
And this And then in Britain, there's
something called the Glorious
Revolution.
Think of the Glorious Revolution as a
marriage between two empires, the
British Empire
and the Dutch Republic, okay?
England
and
Dutch Republic. But at this point in
history, 1688, the Dutch Republic is the
richest area of the world because it
controls the spice trade. In this time
in history, spice is the most valuable
commodity. The problem with the Dutch
Republic is that
it cannot defend itself in Europe, okay?
It's easy It's easily invaded. It's also
Protestant.
So, and they are being attacked by the
Catholics, Catholic France, Catholic uh
the Catholic Church, as well as the
Habsburgs,
the Holy Roman Empire. So, what they
agree to do is they combine they agree
to combine their forces.
All right? So, what happens is the
wealth of the Dutch Republic goes to
England.
All right? And creates something called
in 1694
the Church I'm sorry, the Bank of
England.
>> [snorts]
>> Okay? So, this is a private bank
that is not accountable to the public.
What it does is this, it prints money.
And then who buys it?
Parliament buys it.
Okay?
And this is a massive innovation that
allows the the Empire to conquer the
world.
Because before, if you're rich, if you
get if you lend your money to a king to
fight wars, that was dangerous because a
king could die, or the king could lose
the war, or the king could not pay you
back, okay?
But if you lend money to Parliament,
which is the nation-state, then you're
guaranteed to get your money back as
long as
the nation is still around, okay? And at
this time in history, England is the
safest area of Europe because it's an
island protected by the Royal Navy.
All right?
Okay.
So, this is an innovation that forever
changes human history. And there are
three major characteristics of this
system, okay?
The first is the idea of
um
profits
are privatized.
Losses
are socialized.
If you're a rich person in the world,
you want to put your money in the Bank
of England because you just know that
the Bank of England loses money.
If England goes fight a war and it
loses, England pays for it.
But if it wins the war, then you get the
money for it.
Okay? So, this is the first concept you
need to understand. All profits are
privatized.
All losses are socialized, picked up by
the nation-state, the people. That's the
first thing. Second thing is
in this system,
the way you generate wealth is through
activity. And what does that mean? It
means wars.
Right?
So, if I give you money, you have to go
do something with it. You have to go
make more profit, and the way you do
that is through fighting wars. And
that's why um the British Empire started
to expand very quickly around the world
because they needed to generate profits
for the bankers.
Okay? So, this includes of course the
Napoleonic Wars,
seven of them. It includes something
called the Great Game,
a war between Russia and Britain
uh
for control of essentially Asia.
Um
and also India, the conquest of India,
and then
um
the conquest of
of China, okay?
Okay?
Does it make sense? The Opium Wars.
All right. So, profits.
So, the second characteristic is that
you're always creating more activity.
All right?
Okay.
And the third thing
is it's transnationalism.
Okay?
Open borders.
So, it believes that capital should be
able to move around from place to place,
and it has to build systems in order to
move capital from place to place.
Okay? And the last thing I want to talk
about is
Okay, this is great for the bankers, but
the people look at this and they think
that this is an unfair system, which it
is, right?
So, now you have to brainwash the people
into believing this is a fair system.
And that's why you create a new idea
called materialism.
Or money is God.
And so, what was happening was that
transnational capital, Bank of England,
was sponsoring major intellectuals to
come up with the major ideologies to
support the idea that money is God,
okay? And these include
um sorry.
Uh John Locke,
who argued that private property is
a god-given [snorts]
right, okay? It is an inherent right as
much as freedom, as much as happiness,
okay?
Um and he's the founder of of a theory
called empiricism.
And empiricism states that
we can only know what we ourselves
experience.
It is not feasible, it's not practical
to try to come up with a theory of the
world beyond our experience. So, don't
think about God because God is beyond
our experience, okay?
Then you have someone named
uh David Hume.
Okay? David Hume.
And David Hume
argued for skepticism.
And skepticism just says that
everything that you know
is actually
not valid. Because what you know is just
just based on
um
your belief, okay?
So, Rome is the capital of Italy. Have
you been to Rome? Probably not, okay?
So, where did you learn this? You
learned it in school by memorizing this
fact.
So, basically, we should we should be
skeptical of everything we know because
most of stuff we know is either custom
or habit, okay? So, that's the idea of
skepticism. So, now the problem is,
okay,
skepticism and empiricism just means
that we don't really know anything and
God doesn't really exist.
So, how can we design society?
And so, this creates a new idea called
utilitarianism.
Which [snorts] just say that
if it is
useful,
if it gives us pleasure, it must be
good.
Okay? If you if you take drugs and you
are happy with it, it must be good. If
you like spending money, it must be
good. Okay? And this is from Bentham.
And then John Stuart Mill will make some
will make some adjustments to it, okay?
But this becomes the very concept of
liberty.
Right? Liberty just means that you are
free to pursue
as much money making as possible because
that is the ultimate good. That is what
gives you the most pleasure in life,
spending money. Okay? That's what
liberty is. If a country prevents you
from making money and spending money,
it's an evil dictatorship.
A good country allows you to enjoy the
pleasures of making money. Okay? And
then um what will happen is that these
are the three major philosophers of
materialism
um of British liberty. And then you have
people like um Marx come in.
And he will introduce the idea of
dialectic
materialism.
Dialectic materialism.
Which is which is say like the world is
uh is is one of class struggle. It's not
between God and us. It's not between the
divine and the material. It's one
between the poor and the rich. And
that's it, okay?
So Marx is taking out the divine from
the equation. Then you have
um Darwin.
Theory of evolution.
Which basically says we're just animals,
man.
Okay? That's all. We're not divine
beings. We're all just animals. Then you
have you have people like Freud.
Sex is awesome, guys, okay?
That's what we should be doing. We
should be making a lot of money and then
having as much sex as possible because
that's what we are. We're just apes.
Okay? So this becomes the very
foundation
for the idea that money is God.
All right? Okay.
So,
um
what then happens is that transnational
capital, which has conquered the British
Empire, is now seeking new opportunities
for its investments, okay? So, where it
goes next is, of course, America.
The problem is that the Americans just
had a revolution to destroy the American
to get rid of the British Empire, right?
So, the Americans don't want
transnational capital. It doesn't want
Bank of England or City of London to
come in and conquer it.
So, so what happens is the City of
London, the Bank of England, they use
agents in America.
And these agents, of course, are called
uh there's three of them, okay? Well,
there's actually a lot, but these agents
include
John Rockefeller,
Carnegie, okay? Andrew Carnegie,
um J.P. Morgan,
Vanderbilt.
And they will, by themselves,
monopolize different industries with the
resources and the capital of the City of
London and the Bank of England, okay?
So, of course, John Rockefeller
monopolizes oil, okay?
And then what happens is that these very
powerful agents of
um the City of London will get together
and they will create a system modeled
off the Bank of England. And this, of
course, is called the Federal Reserve
System.
All right?
1914.
And strangely enough, after the Federal
Reserve System
uh is created, three things happen,
right? The first is that America enters
World War I.
Then you have the 1929
um
1929 stock market collapse, followed by
Great Depression, and then 1941, America
joins World War II. Do you understand?
So, Federal Reserve System means that
like Britain
um
America is now controlled by
transnational capital.
Right? And it's the same system now,
where
uh profits are prioritized, losses are
socialized.
And where it's important to open the
country up to capital movement.
All right? Okay. So, as we know, America
wins World War II, and what it does now
is that it tries to move the system all
over the world, specifically Japan and
Europe, okay? Where where it is where
it's able to to control
um the territory.
And eventually, it fights a Cold War
with the Soviet Union, but then it wins.
And then um it it basically
um after collapse of Soviet Union, for
the next 20 30 years, it has complete
control over the world. Something that
we call the uni- unipolar moment. All
right?
And during the uni- unipolar moment,
what happens is that um manufacturing
from America shifts over to China, and
America completely focuses on finance.
This leads to the 2008 Great Financial
Crisis.
All right.
Okay. So, let me provide some background
about the financial crisis, okay? You
don't You don't have to know everything.
I'm going to give you a lot of details,
but I just want you to understand the
basic structure of it, okay?
So, what allowed the Great Financial
Crisis to happen is something called
subprime.
Okay?
Subprime just means that you're lending
money to people who can't pay you back.
Okay? In this context, it's lending
people lending money uh to poor people
to buy homes. Before banks didn't want
to do that.
Okay?
But there are certain things that
happened to make subprime
um
happen, okay? So the first thing is that
Bill Clinton
he really wanted to increase minority
ownership
of homes.
Okay? He wanted black people to buy more
homes.
But again, black people were
historically poor, so the banks didn't
really lend money to them. And that's
why uh Bill Clinton encouraged the
government to help minority homeowners
uh sorry, mi- minorities buy homes,
okay? So that's the first thing.
Okay? And this this was a noble goal.
But something that happened, which is
more important, is in 1999,
Bill Clinton repealed something called
the
Glass-Steagall
Act.
And what is this? The Glass-Steagall Act
just said that if you are a bank
and you take money
from depositors, you cannot engage in
risky lending.
Okay? If you are a investment bank,
okay? If you're a retail bank, you
cannot engage in risky
lending. But if you're an investment
bank or private bank, you can engage in
risky lending. And so that's what the
act said, very simple, okay?
It's It's trying to mitigate risk in the
system.
But by repealing the Glass-Steagall Act,
what what you do is you combine retail
and investment together.
And so these banks now become very
large. And once they become very large,
they need to create financial vehicles
in order to generate more profit, okay?
And at the same time, what's happening
is that because America has the unipolar
moment, everyone wants to invest in
America because they think America is
the safest place to put your money,
okay? So, this includes the GCC, the
China,
Europe and its pension funds, and also
Japan, okay? Japan is investing in
America because of something called the
yen carry trade.
And this is one of the one of the
dumbest things in the world because at
this time in history, Japan is suffering
from deflation, right? No one's spending
any money. So, what the government does
is that it lends money out to
institutions
at 0% interest,
okay?
Now, these institutions are supposed to
take this money and promote more
liquidity in the system. But instead,
what they do is they take this money and
use it to borrow or buy US Treasuries,
which provide 5%
pay, okay? So, you're borrowing money at
0% and then lending it out at 5%,
and it's something called the yen carry
trade, okay? It's one of the dumbest
things in the world.
Um we won't go into it, but again,
there's massive money coming into the US
financial markets, and they need to
create more investment vehicles for
investors, okay? And they create
something called the CDOs,
which means collateral debt obligations,
okay? But basically, it just means
subprime,
all right?
Um the idea is is that mortgages are a
good investment because
people have to pay a monthly mortgage,
right? Therefore, you're guaranteed
certain money at the end of the month,
okay? The problem, of course, is
subprime could lead to default.
Okay? But,
at this time in history, no one was
concerned about default because of the
idea of
too big to fail.
Which means that look, the system is
structured so that everyone is involved.
And if
these homeowners default, and the banks
default, then the entire economy
collapses.
Okay? So, the idea is too big to fail.
The system will keep on going because if
a certain percentage of homeowners were
to default, the entire housing market
would collapse.
Okay? Doesn't make sense, guys.
All right. So, this is one big Ponzi
scheme.
But, we know for a fact that in 2008,
this system collapsed.
And for the longest time, what we
believed is it's because the the
defaults
were too many. They were too much. And
so, the system had to collapse.
But, if you look at what happened,
what you will discover is that's not
true. Okay?
The banks could just choose to roll over
the default, okay? Meaning, okay, you
owe me a thousand dollars, right?
For the mortgage, but you can't pay me.
What do I do? Well, I say, "Pay me back
next month."
Right? You're like, "Next month you
can't pay me back?" Don't worry. Pay me
back the month after, okay? I can have
the system keep on going. Because
remember, the system, this money is is
just based on an illusion. Doesn't make
sense, guys.
All right.
But,
but it collapsed.
Okay? So, that's something that we're
going to look at today. All right. So,
as you can see from this um
map, um this chart, at first what was
happening was that um the government was
one issuing out
loans, okay? So, the government is
basically light blue.
But then, because this industry was so
profitable, private banks started to
come in and issue their own loans. And
these became very risky loans.
Okay?
And this led, of course, to 2008, when
the entire thing collapsed.
Okay. All right.
So,
the the big question is, why did the
financial market collapse? So, this is
the CDO issuance, okay? And as you can
see, it's generating a lot of money for
these private banks. And then suddenly,
in 2008, there's this massive default,
it collapses.
Question is, why did this happen?
And again, you're taught in an English
class, this is just the law of gravity,
okay? If you go too high, you're going
to fall.
But what people don't tell you is this.
There are actually people who made a lot
of money because of the collapse.
John Paulson.
How much money did he make in this
collapse?
20 billion dollars, guys. That's a lot
of money.
20 billion dollars.
How did he make his money? He made his
money by betting that the house market
would collapse.
You understand what happened, okay? So,
so think about this, okay?
I lend
a million dollars to Amber, okay?
And everyone, you got to pay back 10,000
dollars.
But then suddenly, you can't pay me
back, right? But if I tell you,
Amber,
you can't pay me back, you have to give
me your home, okay? Then I lose my
investment in you, right?
So, I don't do that. I I keep on letting
you live in the house, pretend that you
can pay me back even though you can't
pay me back.
But then Vincent says to me, "Hey Mr.
Jeff, I bet you that Amber will not
default on her loan
because she hasn't defaulted in the past
10 years."
I say to Vincent, "How much you want to
bet me?" And he's like,
"Um half a million dollars."
Okay? He's so confident that you will
not default, right?
So I say, "Sure Vincent, I'll take this
bet with you." Right?
Now what I do, now I make you default
cuz now I can make a million dollars
from Vincent.
And that's how it work, guys.
You think it's a very complicated thing?
It's not. It's all a giant scam because
only a few people control the entire
system. This is how you make 20 billion
dollars
in this game, okay? You
There's stupid people buying mortgages
from you, right? But there are even more
stupid people who bet that you will not
default on these mortgages. And you so
you take your money from the stupidest
people. And that's why this system
collapsed. Because you can make more
money from collapsing the system than
just letting it go on.
Okay?
This is This is John Paulson.
This is
Jamie Dimon.
And he also profited from the bank
collapse. Why? Because when these banks
collapsed, you can start to consolidate
the banking industry, okay? So JP Morgan
start to buy these other banks that were
losing money. And then JP Morgan now now
is the largest bank in America.
All right?
Also, guys,
look at this.
Before 2000 and and
8,
most homes were actually owned
by
individuals, okay? This is 2008, okay?
So So the gray are just individuals.
They might have one home, they might
have 10 homes. Okay, but this is
basically individuals.
The blue are those who own more than a
thousand houses.
And then the dark blue are those big
banks that own like hundred thousands of
homes. Okay?
So, before 2008, you can see like most
people were in the gray. Okay?
These are just individuals.
But then, after collapse, you see the
blue and the dark blue rock go way up.
Why? Because
these homeowners lost their homes.
And so these banks
and these companies can come in and buy
them on the cheap. Does that make sense?
So, it's not So, the great financial
crisis of 2008 destroyed millions of
lives, but it made it made it profitable
for a few powerful individuals and
institutions.
Okay?
All right. A major consequence
So, so then you're like, "Okay, no, no,
NO. NO, MR. YANG, YOU DON'T GET IT. It's
gravity."
Eventually, a bubble has to collapse.
Well, okay. Well, today we have two
bubbles.
We have something called the private
equity bubble.
Private credit bubble. Okay? Where
private banks lend money to private
companies.
And people say it's two trillion
dollars.
And it hasn't collapsed yet. Why?
Because the private banks
allow
the private companies who are losing
money to keep on going. You understand?
The The private banks don't come and
say, "Hey, you guys are losing money. I
you should declare bankruptcy and I'll
take whatever you have."
Why? Because they would lose a lot of
money that way.
Okay, do you understand this idea?
These bubbles can keep on going forever.
They don't have to collapse. Another big
bubble today is something called the AI
bubble, right?
>> [snorts]
>> These companies, Nvidia, Open AI, when
they their AI products don't actually
make any money. Like ChatGPT doesn't
actually make any money. In fact, it
loses money
every every time you use it, okay?
Because it's more expensive to run
ChatGPT than it generates in revenue.
But it's it's it's a huge bubble. But
why doesn't collapse? Because these are
just a few companies lending money to
each other. Okay? That's all it is. It's
a giant Ponzi scheme. It's an inside
game. So bubbles don't have to collapse.
They collapse when it's profitable for a
few individuals to make it collapse.
All right? Okay.
Another idea I want you to understand is
that
um [snorts] after the 2008 great
financial crisis, this created problems
in the global economy.
And so what happened was transnational
capital decided to
to save the global economy by allowing
China to rise.
Okay? You get So this is not known, but
one major consequence of the great
financial crisis is that transnational
capital
encouraged China to print money.
Okay?
All right. So I'm going to show you how.
But um
But but first let's let's talk about the
main mechanism to allow this happen.
It's called the Bank of International
Settlements, okay? And this is
um
the Bank of International Settlements
is in Basel, Switzerland.
And it's considered
the central bank
of central banks.
So every nation has a central bank,
okay, that determines interest rate.
But the BIS is the central bank of
central banks, which coordinates all
central banks.
All right? And it is the most powerful
bank in the world. All right. And you
think that okay, this must be public.
No, it's not public. It is run
um in the best in it's managed for the
best interest of powerful people in the
world, okay?
All right. So, um this is in the book,
Basel uh Tower of Basel, okay? Uh
Can Can you Can you read?
For despite
uh Hitler's bluster and
Schatz. planning, Nazi Germany had not
achieved autarky. It needed to buy vast
amounts of raw materials to manufacture
armaments and to feed, heat, and clothe
its population. Swedish steel, Romanian
oil, Portuguese
tungsten, even South American beef all
had to be purchased and paid for in hard
currency. Nazi Germany needed a
financial channel to the neutral
countries. It ran through Basel, which
is the main reason why Nazi Germany did
not invade Switzerland or Sweden.
These neutral countries were far more
used to the Third Reich as
>> Third Reich. Reich. Yes, Third Reich as
monetary hubs on the transnational
financial network than as extra
Schwather
Schwaths of German controlled territory.
>> Okay, so what this means is this.
In his speeches, Hitler promised
independence from the global financial
order controlled by the British, okay?
But you can't really do that because you
still have to buy things
from other places.
But But then you're like,
I need a bank to uh lend me money to buy
things, but also help me facilitate
transactions.
Okay, this is the idea of transnational
capital.
And transnational capital, they don't
really care if you're evil. They don't
care. All they care about is how can I
make money? So, this this bank, Bank of
International Settlements, and tries on
the tries on the capital was helping to
fund the Nazi war machine because it was
profitable to do so.
Okay?
You think, okay, after Hitler lost, the
Americans would surely know, okay, Bank
of International Settlements is evil
because they helped the Nazis.
Therefore, we should destroy the Bank of
International Settlements, okay? But
that's not what happened.
After World War II, the Bank of
International
Bank of International Settlements became
even more powerful, okay? All right. All
right. Can you can you read Amber?
Marshall Aid came at a price. Remodeling
European societies on American model of
consumerism and consumption. Half man's
propaganda arm produced pamphlets,
posters, leaflets, radio programs, and
even traveling puppet shows that
extolled the American lifestyle. The
American dream, a house in the suburbs,
a car, and numerous household appliance
was projected as a near guaranteed
benefit of American style freedom. The
key to this was increased productivity
on American style production lines in a
transnational free market. For that to
happen and for the money to flow freely,
new mechanisms of international payment
had to be constructed with the BIS at
the center. Okay. So, the world is run
for money, okay? The world exists These
organizations exist in order to
facilitate the easy fluid movement of
money around the world.
And they money god. Okay? So, after
2008, the Bank of International
Settlements had a problem in that the
global economy was slowing down.
Europe had lost a lot of money. America
had lost a lot of a lot of money. So,
their solution was, let's shift the
center of gravity from America and
Europe to China. And you're like, okay,
how do you do that then? You do that
with something called the exchange rate.
Okay? Exchange rate is very simple.
Um RMB
to USD.
Okay?
So, remember how the interest rate in a
natural economy it's a signaling
mechanism as to whether or not to
increase or decrease liquidity. Well,
the exchange rate in the national
marketplace is a signaling mechanism to
tell other nations
whether or not to trade with another
nation. Okay, does that make sense to
you guys? All right. So, let's look at
what happened.
>> [snorts]
>> So, for the longest time
the Chinese currency was trading above
eight
to the US dollar. Because remember the
US dollar is the main mechanism
is the main mechanism
um of global trade.
And then, hey, starting around this
time, 2008 guys,
it start to
increase in value.
Okay? And so now the world knows, "Oh, I
should trade with China."
And China is like, "Well, okay, my
exchange rate is higher than before.
Therefore, I should buy more things from
the world."
Okay?
But knowing that, but now that I have
access to commodities from the world,
that that then I should know I need to
promote my economy to use these
resources. So, I should spend more money
on infrastructure. I should build more
high-speed railways. I SHOULD BUILD
AIRPORTS.
OKAY?
And that's what China did. You see how
2008, just as the
American and European economies are
suffering, the global economy is
suffering, the Chinese economy
um
uh China start to have a high exchange
rate, okay? And it kept on going higher
higher and higher.
And then what what what are you trying
to do, vid? Try to start to
buy stuff from around the world with it.
Okay? Again, this is a signaling
mechanism where the Bank of
International Settlements is saying to
the world, you you can now sell to
China. We will guarantee
China.
All right? And And that's because the
Bank of International Settlements needed
to try to buy more things from the
world. And this is happening starting
around 2008, right? This massive surge
in imports.
And because the all the commodities were
coming into China,
China China needed to spend these
commodities, so it started to build
infrastructure, right? And And how did
it finance the building of this
infrastructure?
Bank loans, guys.
Bank loans.
All right?
So, this is China.
Sorry.
This is This is China, right? Look at
this. Look Look Look at this.
Look at this.
This is China.
2008 2008
Basically, China, US, Japan, Europe,
their economies were about the same. The
bank systems were about the same. But
starting about 2008, wow.
Look at this.
This has all been orchestrated by the
Bank of International Settlements, by a
few people working behind the scenes.
Look at this.
Look at how crazy this is.
All right? So, what what does this mean?
It means that today
China has the largest banks in the
world. This is JP Morgan, the largest
bank
in America.
This is Chinese. This is Chinese. This
is Chinese. This is Chinese.
This is Japanese.
Okay? The top four banks
>> [clears throat]
>> in the world are Chinese.
Why? Because
in the in the bank system, debts are
liabili- I'm sorry. Debt liabilities are
also assets. Do you understand?
All this money that the Chinese banks
have are just liabilities.
Okay?
So, this is how the system works. It's
all just an illusion.
Um the thing about the Chinese system
um that prevents it from imploding is
the fact that
all debt in China is localized instead
of nationalized. All right? So, even
though these Chinese banks are heavily
in debt, it's they're they're in debt in
local areas, not national areas, okay?
And all this means is that um
the Bank of China does not have that
much debt relative to, say, the Bank of
Japan.
Okay? So, debt in Japan is nationalized.
Debt in China is localized.
All right?
Okay. So, another major consequence of
China
um the Chinese the growth of the Chinese
um bank system is that China started to
export its goods around the world more,
okay? So, as you can see, in the year
2000,
America
um really dominated the world
in manufacture export, okay? But by the
year 2024, look, it's basically the
entire world um
is buying Chinese exports.
All right?
And so,
um this is a deliberate strategy
of [snorts]
Chinese national capital to move the
center of economic gravity from the
United States to China.
And the problem with China, the reason
why China has not become the hegemon is
that
China's not interested in being the
hegemon. Me In other words, military
power.
Also, as China's is expanding
um its manufacturing capacity to the
world, who's upset now? The United
States, right?
And so what the United States does is it
imposes tariffs.
Okay?
That makes sense. All right. So, in
other words, okay?
Even though
in theory
the theory is that
the goal of the bankers
is to maintain the game, okay?
That's all they care about. So, they
want to switch from America
to China.
But it didn't really work because China
doesn't really want to
take the responsibility of being the
global reserve currency as well as
having military bases overseas. All
right? So, China's China doesn't want to
do this and America won't let China do
this.
So, your only option now is Israel.
Okay?
And that's why I believe that this war
in Iran, what it will do is shift the
center of gravity from America to Israel
because Israel wants to be the center of
the world, not China.
Okay? Does Does that make sense, you
guys?
All right. The other thing you have you
have to understand is that for this to
happen though
transnational capital needs to first
collapse the American economy.
And there are different ways they can do
that, right? They can collapse the
private it private credit bubble, they
they can collapse the AI bubble, they
can collapse both at the same time. And
why would they want to do that? Because
as a banker, as transnational
transnational capital, you make your
money through activity. All right?
When people go and do stuff, whether
it's entrepreneurship or starting wars?
But they have to go do stuff.
And right now America has a lot of
problems, okay? So so let's let's look
at America's problems.
First is aging, where the elite are now
older and older. They therefore they are
less active. They are less energetic.
They are less entrepreneurial, okay?
Then you have something called
quantitative easing, which is like too
much money in the system.
You have too much money in the system,
then people do stupid things like
gamble, okay?
All right? And the last problem with
America is
you can't [snorts] win wars.
Okay? Like this Iran situation is
showing that America the
the American military is not as strong
as you think it is. So if you're
transnational capitalist, you see these
three things, okay? The population is
getting too old.
Uh there's too much money around, so
people will do stupid things like
gambling.
And America the American military is not
that great. Then you're going to shift
your capital from America overseas,
okay?
But but before you do that, what you
want to do is engineer a financial
crisis,
so that you can make as much money as
possible, just like the 2008 financial
crisis, okay? So we don't know when it
will happen, but we can be sure that it
will happen. It will be suddenly, okay?
Okay, does that make sense, guys?
Now, you're like, "Wait a minute here.
What what would Trump
and Americans allow this to happen?"
They know they must know this is coming.
And the answer is because it is in the
long-term
best interests of America for the
economy to collapse and for
transnational capital to go elsewhere.
And this is something we'll discuss next
class, okay? What the long-term American
strategy is.
Transnational capital is leaving
America. So and then they're going to
say, like, "Oh my god, Bank of England,
City of London? These parasites are
leaving? Thank you. Get out of here,
man." Okay? And what will happen is once
they leave, America will probably have a
much brighter future. And something
we'll discuss next class.
But, any questions?
Yeah.
So, seems like that
America is in a disadvantage situation,
but
but they know what they are doing and
they are just sending parasites outside
of their country and having a more
long-term benefit. Is that right?
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay. So, this is something we'll
discuss next class, okay? But, this is
not a deliberate strategy.
All right? Because if you think about
it, economic collapse will destroy a lot
of wealth in America.
It will probably create conditions for
civil war in America. It will create a
lot of pain. But, there are certain
people,
for example, Donald Trump, who believe
that this pain is necessary in order for
America to become great again, okay? He
said His motto is what? Make America
great again. And how do you do that? You
get rid of these parasites.
But, to get rid of parasites, guys, it's
a painful painful process. It's like a
cancer, right? Have you guys been
through cancer treatment?
It's painful. Chemotherapy, they they do
surgery on you. You have to like eat
this, you know, crappy food all the
time. It's a painful process. Okay? So,
transnational capital, it's a parasitic
force, it's a cancer on American host.
They have to get rid of it, but it's
going to be a very painful process that
that's going to take a long time, years,
possibly decades, okay?
Yeah, Amber.
Thank you.
Um so, if transnational capital is
leaving America, then how would you
think this shift would impact the global
economy? Or would it at all?
Yeah, okay.
All right. Yeah, all right. So,
this is something we'll discuss later
on, okay? But, let me just show you how
this shift happens.
All right.
So, right now you're you're in America.
>> [snorts]
>> And the best place for you to shift is
Israel.
Okay? Why? Because
you're interested in activity. Okay?
You're interested in putting your money
in a place where it's going to grow.
Right? And why is Israel growing? Well,
because of the Greater Israel project.
Right? They want to conquer the Middle
East.
But, then it has to rebuild. Right?
After the after the war.
Rebuilding.
And then, what it's going to do is
become the hub of global trade.
Right?
Because Israel controls Africa. And this
is something we'll discuss next class,
okay?
So, this is why you want to invest in
Israel. For these three reasons. Why?
Because they're going to keep on
fighting wars to to achieve the Greater
Israel project. Wars are profitable.
Wars are the most profitable enterprise
in the world, okay? Second is that they
rebuild after all this
after all this destruction. So, they
need capital. The third is they will
control global trade because of because
of the location, okay? So, this is why
Israel is a smart investment for
transnational capital. I'm not talking
about like us, okay? With like $1,000.
I'm talking about like trillions of
dollars will probably go into Israel.
All right. So,
um to leave America, what you want is a
stock market collapse, okay? An an
economic collapse.
Why?
Because economic collapse
not only allows you to leave with with
with as much money as possible, but also
allows you to buy up distressed assets.
And
when I mean distressed assets, I mean
resources.
Which include
water,
oil, okay? So, you want to create as
much damage as possible, because then
it's easier to for you to buy these
resources.
And okay, does that make sense?
Right? So, these guys plan
decades ahead.
But transnational capital, what what
they what what they do is they're trying
to create as much chaos as possible
because in chaos there's profit. Like if
you're just sitting around doing
nothing, you can't make any money, okay?
But if you're fighting each other, if
there's blood on the streets, you can
make a lot of money.
Right?
Does that make sense? Okay.
Any more questions, guys?
Okay, so we'll talk about
what happens after this
financial shift next class, okay?